m'écouter paris et berlin ont assuré ce
soir parler d'une seule et même voix
face à moscou emmanuel macron et olaf
scholz veulent d'une part poursuivre le
dialogue avec la russie et contribuer à
une désescalade il s'agit donc de
multiplier les canaux de communication
avec la reprise notamment du foie ou du
fameux format normandie qui réunit
autour d'une même table la france
l'allemagne l'ukraine et la russie il
s'agit également d'essayer de multiplier
les échanges avec vladimir poutine comme
cet entretien téléphonique qui doit se
tenir vendredi entre le président russe
et le président français mais emmanuel
macron et olaf scholz ont également
souligné ce soir que si cette stratégie
a échoué bien les conséquences d'une
agression russe contre l'ukraine aurait
de graves conséquences
reste toutefois à savoir lesquels pour
l'heure en tout cas olaf scholz refuse
vous le savez de livrer des armes à
l'ukraine pour des raisons historiques
et politiques et il reste également très
très prudent lorsqu'il s'agit d'évoquer
des sanctions concrètes contre la russie
l'allemagne est donc toujours très
réticente pour envoyer des troupes anne
eliane différences entre l'allemagne et
la france
oui il faut bien comprendre que le
chancelier allemand est à la tête d'une
coalition très divisés face à la russie
il ya un côté les écologistes mais aussi
les libéraux de centre-droit qui sont
favorables à une plus grande fermeté
vis-à-vis de moscou et puis de l'autre
il ya le parti social-démocrate son
propre parti donc il ne veut pas aller à
la confrontation
le spd a rock volontiers la tradition de
la host politique de vibrantes une
politique de rapprochement avec l'urss
dans les années 1970 mais au-delà de ça
il ya bien évidemment aussi des intérêts
stratégiques et économiques très
importants l'allemagne est extrêmement
dépendante du gaz russe qui représente
près de la moitié de ses importations de
gaz et par conséquent la question du
gazoduc north stream 2 qui relie la
russie à l'allemagne est
particulièrement épineuse vous le savez
washington et d'autres pays occidentaux
on souhaiterait empêcher la mise en
service de ce gazoduc est que ce s'en
servir comme levier de sanctions contre
moscou mais la plupart des sociaux
démocrates
ils sont opposés ce n'est pas une
surprise puisque ce sont justement ces
mêmes sociaux-démocrates qui avec
l'ancien chancelier gerhard schröder ont
initié ce projet de gazoduc il ya une
quinzaine d'années merci à anan mallet
en direct de berlin c'est avec vous
qu'on referme cette édition et ça sera
le sujet du débat que ces tensions en
ukraine donc rester avec nous